Now I've always been
particularly interested in faces,
and the kind of messages
which we send out
through our faces all the time.
But I would like to show you a slide or two.
[LAUGHTER]
Now I acquired these slides
two years ago
when I first became interested in
this
and I wrote to a number of
department stores in London
and asked them to let me
take portraits of the teddy bears
in their toy departments.
And it had an enthusiastic response
and given every conceivable facility.
And I will show you
a very small selection
of what must be a unique collection
of these photographs which I've got.
And I'll give you a character interpretation
of each of the pictures
which I see and you can tell me
whether you agree with me or not.
Now he seems to me
to be a happy-go-lucky fellow,
very nice as a friend to
go away on a holiday with.
Perhaps a little lightweight
in terms of reliability and so on
but certainly fun
to be with as a friend.
Now he on the other hand
[LAUGHTER]
and sex discrimination apart I think of
all teddy bears as being 'he's.
Are there any she bears in the hall?
Well you see a very very small number.
The sex ratio amongst
bears must be such
as to put the the continuance of
the species into grave jeopardy.
[LAUGHTER]
This is a this is a bear of entirely
different ilk.
I always imagined him
to be a master butcher
in a small provincial town.
[LAUGHTER]
A member of the Town Council,
an alderman maybe,
Very reliable, not by any means
unconscious of his own importance
in his own world,
in the scheme of things
but a really solid,
and possibly stolid, citizen
of this small town.
[LAUGHTER]
He on the other hand I think
is a bit naive.
[LAUGHTER]
he hasn't been around a great deal
I wouldn't give much for his IQ
[LAUGHTER]
but maybe as he grows up
he will he will learn
the ways of the world a bit a bit better.
He is just rude.
[LAUGHTER]
And the last one
I've got a picture of
[LAUGHTER]
seems to me to be a very dangerous
sort of bear.
Very headstrong, I always think
of him as my mafia bear
[LAUGHTER]
I don't think he's actually bright enough
to be in any sense
to occupy one of the
upper posts of the Mafia
but he might be a sort of
local boss of some local cells mafia.
Now I'm going to have a look
at some of the bears
who have come to this lecture,
and see if I can do a character analysis
of some of these.
Could you just move over bear,
so that I can sit down.
Right here this one here looks to me
like a quite an old fellow.
I think he has a very definite
sense of humour,
you can see this by the set of his eyes.
Slightly wry smile on his face on
all the time.
I think he's quite an old bear
and he's already seen life quite a lot
and I understand from his owner
he is in fact fifteen years old
so he has lived in the
family for a long time
I would have thought he was great fun
to have in a family
and that he's seen it all and
he knows it all.
Now I've got another one here
and this one actually I'm informed
has signals from the interior.
[BEAR MAKES GROWLING NOISE]
[LAUGHTER]
I think it's just as well that the ones
which I've been measuring on some of you
have had not to be elicited by
quite such a complicated method
[LAUGHTER]
Now he seems to me to be different sort of bear at all
I think he likes his gin
[LAUGHTER]
And I can just just imagine
him going along to the local,
and with one foot up on the bar
holding forth on his experiences
when he was in India
to all the other admiring bears.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is my last one,
perhaps here, I'll have this one here.
Now he looks to me really like
rather a stubborn bear.
I would hate to change
his mind about anything.
Stubborn and maybe narrow-minded too.
But I would have thought
because of his stubbornness
and steadfastness,
he could be great comfort to a child
was perhaps a little
frightened of the dark,
and wanted somebody stout
and steadfast to keep company with.
Now just for small fee, I would do
character analysis on any teddy bears
[LAUGHTER]
which might be submitted to me.